it's our first award this evening is in
the honorary foreign foreign film
category and it will be my pleasure to
make that presentation the academy
working with select the international
association of film and television
schools viewed a record 57 films this
year from 39 different countries prior
to selecting tonight's award winner for
the very first time in our awards
history the winning directors from the
country of Sweden made at the Institute
of drama in Stockholm the winning film
was directed by pair on a fjord in his
entitled elkland in this terrific
character study we meet we meet Henrik
the prodigal son who upon returning home
to help his older brother bury their
father finds his mother seriously ill
please welcome the director of elkland
pair hana fjord i'm trying to make it
sits look at this Oh step back let me
enjoy the moment for a bit it was such a
surprise no I'm only the one and only in
this category so I knew I would one win
tonight so but anyways it still is the
greatest honor so far in my career and
release and being here and watch the
other guys stuff the work they've done I
become even a greater honor and it has
really been an inspiring week and I
really want to thank the academy for
that and of course for this lovely thank
you and during this day I've been
calling up my team members and thanking
them individual today and of course my
girlfriend i tol
them told her that I will thank her
tonight she was very happy amazing okay
and tonight I also have the lead actor
jamie-lynns from playing Henrik please
stand up lovely sit down and I also have
my parents that flew all the way from
Sweden to be here tonight isn't that
just lovely
mama papa you're such great parents hey
let's get here but what else for I just
told him I love them okay I would lie
they told me to keep this short and I've
already used up all the minutes i guess
but i would love to tell you this story
this is such a life changing story so
you might want to pick up your notebooks
and take some notes I don't know because
will only tell this once okay it seems
like the time ran out so maybe we do
this way I would be glad to come back
and tell it another time so please have
me back and i will tell it to
once again thank Academy
you
you